no jaywalking on my watch man claims
police wrongfully arrested and publicly
humiliated him in a sexting operation
undercover cops posing as gay men headed
to public restrooms in Manhattan Beach
California looking to bust any sexual
shenanigans that might be going on maybe
you think twice before you go George
Michael in the bathroom
a detective entered the stall in a
couple minutes later Boyd bolted out of
the adjacent stall and flood the
restroom with a man who was waiting for
him for an unusually long time five
other officers tackled the man outside
and hauled him into the police station
like that wham guy right but it turns
out the man Charles Samuel couch wasn't
a sex criminal he was a caretaker to a
child with a rare genetic disorder whose
symptoms include mental retardation and
difficulty urinating the child takes a
long time to use the bathroom and that's
why couch was spending so much time
waiting in the restroom says coaches
attorney the child bursts from the stall
and runs up to my client says there's a
man looking at me the undercover officer
was looking at the child through a hole
in the stall couch alleges in a recently
filed federal lawsuit about the 2012
incident porno porno porno couch says
the police seized his laptop and kept it
for months searching in vain for porn I
know you're in there porn since all his
schoolwork was on the computer couch had
to withdraw from college months later he
was shocked and humiliated he says to
see his picture along with 19 others in
the paper and on the police website come
on you'll cut some better things to do
there's one of my couches lawsuit claims
the Manhattan Beach police routinely
bust men without probable cause and
publicize the false arrests something
that's all too common across America and
why sex and Western is only an issue in
public restrooms the loads tragedies the
comments perhaps cops could spend more
time on that questions instead of
humiliating guys like couch followed the
show on Twitter submit your nominees for
next month and check out cop block this
month's featured follower is the big
shot with Twitter in me are you
twittering me